merci d'être avec nous Gérard Longuet et
de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure élu de la Meuse vous
êtes membre du groupe les républicains
et Emmanuel Macron prend donc la parole
aujourd'hui à 13h qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de cette intervention
la réforme des retraites était
indispensable Sénat la soutenu le
problème d'ailleurs n'est pas épuisé
pour l'éternité tant sans faut et je
crois que son devoir à lui c'est
d'expliquer la nécessité absolue de
commencer cette retraite et de franchir
une étape qui je le reconnais est une
étape importante une étape difficile
personne n'a envie de travailler plus
mais c'est la réalité des chiffres qui
commandent et je crois qu'il faut
continuer de l'expliquer il s'agit pas
de refermer le bocal il s'agit de dire à
nos compatriotes qu'on a un système
social qui est qui est bien qui est
on n'est pas des élèves c'est pas un
prof simplement qu'il mette les chiffres
sur la table il faut savoir par exemple
que les cotisations retraite ne
représentent que deux tiers des recettes
le troisième tiers 120 milliards
excusez-moi du peu sont des impôts si
ces impôts pouvaient être redistribués
progressivement pour mieux payer les
instituteurs ou pour augmenter certains
fonctionnaires ça serait pas si mal pour
lever trop tard pour les explications
le problème du président Macron c'est
qu'il a renoncé dans son premier
quinquennat une réforme qui était déjà
nécessaire et là il l'a fait rapidement
à la hussard il faut bien le reconnaître
en trois mois départ arrêtés je crois
qu'il faut qu'il continue d'expliquer
que si la France veut tenir son rang si
elle veut investir pour son avenir et si
elle veut mieux payer ceux qui servent
le service public la santé l'éducation
j'évoquais il faut pas il faut mettre
l'argent
là où il y a des il y a des besoins
immédiats et pas nécessairement là où
c'est moins
utile hier soir il a reçu les
parlementaires de sa majorité et il a eu
notamment cette phrase la foule n'a pas
de légitimité face au peuple qui
s'exprime à travers ses élus vous
partagez cette phrase le président
Macron a le sens de la formule qui n'est
pas qui peut-être intellectuellement
vrai mais qui n'est pas humainement très
agréable pour ceux qui sont concernés
parce que la foule c'est quand même des
gens qui ne sont pas forcément mes amis
je ne partage pas leurs convictions mais
quand vous avez des centaines de
milliers de gens qui descendent dans la
rue c'est qu'ils expriment quelque chose
alors ce ne sont pas eux qui font la loi
et nous les sénateurs qui avons je
dirais le privilège d'être un petit peu
plus libre vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique immédiate on n'est pas on peut
pas être dissout par exemple bon c'est
facile de le dire pour un député qui
dans sa circonscription voit 2000
personnes défilées devant sa perman ça
le fait réfléchir quand même donc il
faut respecter les gens qui manifestent
on n'est pas obligé de les suivre mais
il faut les respecter hier il a promis
également d'avancer sur la santé l'école
l'écologie tout en organisation la
société du plein emploi il lui faut de
l'argent et il faut qu'il l'a pas la
France étant d'été la France continue de
s'endetter et la France inquiète nos
partenaires vous savez qu'on nous sommes
dans une famille qui s'appelle l'euro et
dans l'euro il y a ceux qui écoutent et
il y a ceux qui rapportent ceux qui
rapportent pendant un petit sont un peu
fatigué de payer pour ceux qui écoutent
c'est à dire la France il a dit
également hier il y aura pas de
remaniement pas de dissolution pas de
référendum il peut dire ça et faire ça
alors que le rejet de la motion de
censure le non rejet en l'occurrence
c'est fait à 9 mois après je pense que
dans tout pays démocratique européen
dans tout pays parlementaire
lorsqu'il y a une crise les partis
politiques parlent entre eux les groupes
parlementaires parlent entre eux et
force de trouver une solution même
l'Italie il parvient l'Allemagne
naturellement même la Belgique qui
parvienne et je crois que en France on a
un petit peu trop tendance à reposer sur
le sol président de la République mais
là il a passé on va parler de votre
famille politique il a pas essayé de
parler avec les républicains selon vous
de véritables négociations parties
dit on a obtenu des choses on a obtenu
des 64 ans on a obtenu la revalorisation
et tous les retraités c'est vrai qu'il y
a eu des choses par exemple Sénat et la
majorité républicaine du Sénat majeur
République et décentriste a obtenu des
avancées significatives notamment pour
les maires de famille mais c'est pas ça
c'est pas grappiller c'est se mettre
autour d'une table et passer les
semaines de discussion nécessaire pour
fixer des objectifs alors ça c'est pas
du tout comme ça le président Macron a
une idée il l'annonce à son gouvernement
qu'il faut mettre en œuvre telle mesure
et puis
à charge pour le ministre de trouver
quelques alliés pour passer le cap c'est
pas une négociation mais comme LR je
dois balayer devant ma porte il y a ceux
nous ne savons pas organiser la
démocratie interne de notre partie il y
a ceux qui parlent trop une fois que la
décision a été prise il faut la
respecter et il y a ceux qui ne parlent
pas c'est à dire qu'il reste dans leur
dans leur montagne ou leur montagne leur
plaine loin de Paris et qui attendent
tranquillement la région
Auvergne ou nord de la France ou même
région parisienne
les trois grands candidats
on les a pas beaucoup entendu à cette
occasion on va parler tout de suite des
républicains de votre famille politique
puisque cette séquence retraite a divisé
votre partie
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
depuis lundi et le vote sur la motion de
censure rien ne va plus chez elle oui
mais certains vont peut-être mieux que
d'autres sans du parti 19 députés LR
sont actuellement sous le feu des
projecteurs ils ont voté la motion de
censure déposée par le groupe iote lundi
on rappelle que les LR à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est 61 députés on a donc un
tiers un tiers des élus qui ont donné
leur suffrage à une censure de
gouvernement sur une réforme pourtant
demandée par la droite depuis plusieurs
années on va voir les noms s'afficher
parmi ces députés on trouve évidemment
Aurélien Pradier partisan d'une droite
sociale chef de fil de ce qu'on peut
maintenant appeler les frondeurs il y a
aussi des proches de Laurent Wauquiez
comme Isabelle Valentin Fabien dit
Philippot ou encore Fabrice brun tous
ont fait filles de la ligne imposée par
Éric Ciotti et Olivier Marleix qui ne
souhaitait pas que le groupe vote la
motion et donc plusieurs lignes au sein
du même parti et dans ce contexte
certains responsables reviennent à la
charge il souhaite passer un accord avec
Emmanuel Macron et revoilà Rachida Dati
vendredi dernier l'ancienne ministre de
Nicolas Sarkozy s'est exprimée sur
France Culture écouter là
aujourd'hui il y a pas beaucoup
d'options qui restent au président de la
République je pense qu'il faudra
aujourd'hui à un véritable accord
politique un contrat de gouvernement
pour que les forces réformatrices de ce
pays travaillant ensemble pour
évidemment redresser le pays aujourd'hui
revient aussi à notre famille politique
de prendre cette responsabilité et de
voir avec le président Macron de voir
comment on a un accord politique pour
redresser transformer et réformer ce
pays l'idée d'un accord entre LR et les
macronistes n'est pas nouvelle elle
avait été évoquée par Nicolas Sarkozy
lui-même dans le Journal du dimanche on
date du 23 octobre l'ancien chef de
l'État suggérait à Emmanuel Macron de
chercher à faire un accord politique en
bonne et due forme avec toutes les
bonnes volontés prêtes à constituer une
majorité dans l'intérêt supérieur du
pays fin de citation à ses avances
Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais répondu et au
sein du parti la proposition avait à
l'époque également été mal accueilli
elle ne récolte toujours pas les
suffrages écoutez
produit moins que jamais nous devons
refuser notre rôle notre responsabilité
c'est d'être des opposants à Emmanuel
Macron mais par pitié je crois encore
une fois ne confondons pas tout lorsque
le gouvernement est contraint par des
raisons extérieures et notamment par ses
engagements européens et contraint de
faire une réforme des retraites que nous
demandons depuis très longtemps il me
paraissait absurde d'être incohérent au
point de contredire ce que nous avions
demandé nous-mêmes depuis si longtemps
ça ne veut pas dire que je ne suis pas
un opposant je suis et je reste un
opposant à la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron qui fait tant de mal à la France
pas d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron c'est
aussi votre avis Gérard Longuet
le problème français c'est qu'on a perdu
depuis très longtemps l'habitude de
négocier négocier n'est pas un mot
obscène
se parler est une nécessité absolue dans
toutes les démocraties je vous rappelle
qu'aucun président de la République n'a
jamais eu la majorité absolue dans notre
pays sur son nom au premier tour d'une
élection et compris le général de Gaulle
le président
mais il y a deuxième cas de figure très
particulier c'est que le président
Macron ne peut pas se représenter et
donc et il n'a pas d'avenir immédiat
peut-être dans 25 ans que sais-je il est
jeune il a pas d'avenir immédiat le
rôle d'un parti politique c'est quand
même de contribuer à diriger un pays et
à orienter un pays si nous avons notre
place pourquoi pas seul problème ce
qu'on ne l'a jamais proposé
débaucher des talents il y en a
quelques-uns au gouvernement
le maire Édouard Philippe bien de chez
nous sont des talents mais c'est pas une
force politique parce qu'il représente
pas notre famille en totalité
c'est un mode de décider entre nous elle
est là où je suis en désaccord total non
pas sur le fond avec Bellamy ou avec
Dati c'est que c'est question il faut
d'abord en parler entre nous
on est pas du tout sur la même ligne
mais on n'a pas d'enceinte pour parler
et on n'a pas de mécanique démocratique
interne ou LR pour trancher pourquoi
Aurélien pralier a-t-il été jusqu'au
bout et à voter une censure parce qu'ils
ne se sentait pas obligé par la décision
du parti parce que le parti n'a pas
d'organisation interne suffisamment
démocratique et suffisamment reconnue
pour qu'une décision majoritaire et le
groupe Olivier Marlet c'est à la tête
d'un groupe il a une majorité au sein de
votre part
les députés ont dit on ne vote pas l'âme
la censure mais c'est la position sur la
réforme des retraites il y a eu un vote
par qui par un bureau politique
c'est-à-dire que les gens ne se sentent
pas concernés dans ma propre fédération
qui d'ailleurs très faible actuellement
les gens m'ont dit à non non pas
question de d'aider le président et
l'autre on dit pas question de rater une
chance de rénover le système mais tout
ça n'est pas remonté au sommet il n'y a
pas eu en quelque sorte une assemblée
générale du parti disons bon ben on y va
il y aura sûrement des minoritaires mais
les minoritaires ont tort parce que ils
ne sont pas représentatifs aujourd'hui
vous le dites très justement il y a un
tiers qui pense le contraire des deux
tiers dans un parti politique quand il y
a deux tiers d'un côté c'est une belle
majorité et on devrait la suivre sauf
que ce n'est pas organisé à l'intérieur
de notre partie et donc
les ténors se taisent avez-vous entendu
Laurent Wauquiez non avez-vous entendu
avez-vous compris Xavier Bertrand non
les ténors se tait et les oui les les
individualités brillantes Madame Dati
est une femme de caractère Jean-François
Copé est un homme intelligent très
intelligent même s'exprime mais il
s'exprime à titre individuel ce qui
manque et c'est le rôle de Derrick
sciotique qui en est tout à fait capable
ceux qui manque c'est une démocratie
interne qui fasse que lorsque une
décision est prise elle s'impose et que
les points de vue dissidents ne soient
des points de vue dissidents
ce qui manque c'est un chef non c'est un
chef c'est une démocratie interne le
chef ça veut rien dire chef à l'armée
oui vous nommez un général ça j'ai connu
ça j'étais mineur mais un parti
politique c'est pas un chef un parti
politique c'est une majorité qui se
dégage avec des gens qui n'a pas
suffisamment d'autorité nous avons
président qui organise son travail mais
tout est arrivé si vite qu'on ne peut
pas le reprocher de
ne pas avoir en organiser le débat parce
que c'est un peu le je reviens sur le
président Macron il fait il fait tout ça
en un mois et demi comment voulez-vous
que c'est partenaires ses propres alliés
d'ailleurs vous savez il y a des chez
odennes à horizon à Renaissance compris
les gens qui n'ont pas voté ou qui
n'auraient pas voté le texte pourquoi
parce qu'il y a pas eu ce débat interne
précédent Macron ne peut pas gouverner
la France seule voilà donc en général
chez dit Salier c'est se diluer il a
tort
s'allier c'est se diluer il a tort se
sépare je non c'est ce que fait le
président l'archet il gère une majorité
sénatoriale qui n'est pas homogène nous
avons des centrices habitions s'entend
très bien des indépendants avec qui on
s'entraîne très bien mais on n'est pas
toujours d'accord sur tous les sujets et
donc le président l'archet est un homme
qui négocie et qui construit des
majorités il y a des députés donc il
faut faire la même chose pour le pays
parce que entre nous la situation de la
France pané moins de le dire je ne parle
avec un peu de passion mais à produire
des dettes à produire des déficits avoir
un service public qui se dégrade avoir
une confiance dans l'état qui diminue
chaque jour et avoir des autorités
autoproclamées qui décide qu'on doit
faire ceci ou faire cela dans le
l'irrespect total des procédures
législatives au gouvernementales c'est
mériterait quand même qu'on travaille un
petit peu ensemble donc ça c'est le fond
de ma conviction c'est que la France a
besoin qu'on travaille ensemble mais
pour travailler ensemble il faut quand
même des règles du jeu où chacun se
respecte et où on ne cherche pas en
disant ça y est j'en tiens non c'est on
prend tout et ceux qui veulent sont
respectés ceux qui veulent pas sont
opposants mais une fois que la décision
est prise on travaille pour quatre ans
de censure déposer pas le Rassemblement
National 3 députés à l'air ont voté pour
cette motion et bien s'abstenir parce
que le rassemblement national ne porte
en rien les solutions du pays que Madame
Le Pen soit plus intelligente que son
père ou Puzzo plus calme allez que son
père c'est une évidence
mais le RN ne porte aucune des solutions
sur les régimes de retraite silence
assourdissant du RN qui nous invente une
cotisation à 43 ans qui est simplement
impossible le RN n'a aucune solution
mais il est propre sur lui parce que ça
veut dire qu'ils sont en train de sauter
justement entre les LR et le
rassemblement national je pense que il y
a pas besoin de digue il y a besoin d'un
débat ce que je reproche au RN c'est pas
d'être RN ce que je reproche à Marine Le
Pen c'est pas de s'appeler Le Pen ce que
je lui reproche c'est de ne pas avoir de
solutions courageuses et l'esquive les
solutions en essayant de faire plaisir à
tout le monde c'est elle aussi et dans
le en même temps et ces trois députés
est-ce qu'il faut les exclure
je pense qu'il faut qu'il nous explique
pourquoi ils ont voté c'est cette
censure alors si pour des raisons
électorales locales ça peut arriver
c'est l'explication que je préférerais
parce que s'ils avaient lu le texte
enfin l'absence de solutions du RN et
c'est se déconsidérer que de voter pour
une non solution que porte le RN
triomphe allemand
alors qu'en fait c'est lui vide c'est du
vide et c'est du vide sur Laurent
Wauquiez donc vous déplorez le silence
eriksiotti vous voulez en faire le
candidat à la présidentielle des
républicains
est intelligent il cache toutes les
cases sympathiques il y a quand même un
moment il faut aller au charbon et dire
ça ça va ça ça va pas la France elle vit
tous les jours elle ne vit pas que tous
les 5 ans au moment de la présidentielle
et on n'a pas le droit de d'ailleurs
Bel-Ami l'a dit assez honnêtement on n'a
pas le droit de ne rien faire c'est tout
simplement il faut faire tous les jours
quelque chose utile pour crédibiliser
pour vous pour être votre candidat à la
présidentielle en parlant pas je lui dis
très très amicalement qu'on aimerait
qu'il parle
il y a trop de gens qui parlent pendant
rien dire et qui n'ont pas d'autorité
pour que quelqu'un qui a de l'autorité
et qui aide la compétence puisse
toujours se taire c'est lui qui a tiré
les ficelles selon vous lors de ce vote
à la semaine prochaine
c'est pas très clair il n'a pas tirer
les ficelles ni Xavier Bertrand
d'ailleurs dès que Xavier Bertrand en
effet
le prochain texte
que vous prochaine le Sénat devait
examiner le projet de loi immigration
finalement l'examen va être reporté
c'était une demande de Gérard Larcher
accepté par Emmanuel Macron qu'en
pensez-vous que c'est très bien c'est
pas mûr il y a dans ce texte des sujets
qui ne sont pas encore
approfondies et partagés par une
éventuelle majorité parlementaire or
comme il n'y a pas de majorité
parlementaire certaines il n'est pas
inutile de je veux dire il vaut mieux
perdre trois mois et gagner plusieurs
années mais il faut garder l'examen tel
quel c'est-à-dire avec un projet de loi
globale un peu en même temps une partie
droite une partie gauche ou est-ce qu'il
faut le synthé en deux avec la partie
portée par Gérald Darmanin et la partie
portée par Olivier du saute
je suis pas capable de répondre je pense
qu'il faut une vision globale le vrai
problème français c'est la démographie
portée à la démographie
ça suppose on serait beaucoup plus
tranquille vis-à-vis de l'immigration
avec une politique familiale qui nous
laissait espérer un renouveau
démographique vous savez qu'il y a
100000 jeunes naissances en naissant
moins chaque année merci Cécile on
parlera de la guerre de l'eau tout à
l'heure autre ambiance exactement ce
sera à suivre dans le club on va
continuer à parler de la réforme des
retraites et l'adoption de cette réforme
par le Parlement qui n'éteint pas la
contestation loin de là manifestation et
blocage perdure voire s'amplifier
direction la Normandie retrouver ses
rires habillé bonjour Thierry merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef de Paris Normandie Thierry comment
s'est passé la nuit du côté de la
Normandie
la nuit s'est passé plutôt calme par
rapport à ces derniers jours
un démarrage de semaine plutôt musclé du
côté de la zone industrielle à la braise
avec des blocages très tôt le matin sur
la zone industrielle puisque vous savez
que la raffinerie totale énergie a
reproduit à reconduite sa grève en 96
heures jusqu'à vendredi la cime donc
cette zone d'approvisionnement cette ce
cette zone où le pétrole arrive non
raffiné et qui permet ensuite
d'alimenter les raffineries de Total à
Gonfreville et Dexon mobile à Port
Jérôme sur scène ne fonctionne plus donc
elle peut rien qui rentre plus rien qui
sort donc cheixon il y a une
problématique qui va qui va arriver dans
quelques heures quelques jours c'est
qu'il y aura plus de matière première à
raffiner mais pour l'instant ce matin on
a quelques blocages du côté de Dieppe à
l'entrée de Dieppe quelques blocages sur
la zone industrielle rouennaise mais on
est sur une un début de matinée très
calme sur fond des actions sociales
Thierry vous avez des questions
oui mais j'entendais Gérard Longuet par
les longuements et notamment de ce qui
se passe dans son parti un peu de qui
pourrait incarner incarner une droite en
France et qu'est-ce qui manque
finalement j'ai relongé à Emmanuel
Macron pour vraiment être un homme de
droite un président de droite et être
finalement votre votre meilleure
porte-parole pour déclencher les
réformes de ce pays
le sens du partage de la décision
politique
je lui reproche pas d'être un homme de
droite ou ne pas être d'être trop à
gauche c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
que la discussion avec lui est très
difficile parce qu'elle n'est pas
équilibrée c'est un homme que je connais
un tout petit peu il adore convaincre et
il vous parle inlassablement jusqu'au
moment où vous êtes de son avis or le il
faut savoir apprendre à négocier à
prendre à
accepter parfois renoncer et il ne sait
il ne le fait pas parce qu'il n'a pas
cette habitude
c'est en tous les cas c'est pas son
comportement souvenez-vous de la
formidable tournée après les gilets
jaunes il a commencé d'ailleurs dans
votre région dans le département de
l'Eure à l'initiative de Sébastien
Lecornu mais quand vous avez un
président de la République qui parle
inlassablement les élus locaux que nous
sommes je suis c'est vrai qu'on l'écoute
on le respecte mais ce n'est pas un vrai
dialogue parce que dans un vrai dialogue
la hiérarchie que vous donne votre
statut ne vient pas arbitrer la
discussion voilà et pour l'instant il
est sur le dialogue tout en revendiquant
son statut de président pour expliquer
qu'il y a un moment le dialogue s'arrête
non ou on sait pas c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche c'est donc pas le fond qui
me gêne chez lui c'est la façon de de
partager la décision pour revenir aux
manifestations et au blocage dont
parlait Thierry votre collègue sénateur
LR Stéphane lerudulier veut limiter le
droit de rêve dans les raffineries à une
fois par semaine pas plus de trois jours
consécutifs pour éviter le blocage de
l'économie est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à ça
le plus souvent quand on applique la loi
ça marche assez bien ce qui pose des
lois nouvelles c'est parce qu'on
n'applique pas les lois existantes moi
je préfère comme je suis paresseux je
préfère faire marcher ce qui existe
plutôt que d'inventer de nouveaux
systèmes vous avez réacquisitions ça
vous êtes favorable le casier chiant les
réquisitions j'ai commencé ma vie
politique dans ma vie administrative en
68 à la direction des carburants et nous
réquisitionnions des gendarmes mobiles
pour libérer les
raffineries bloquées par les 68 âge
bornière elle a accusé la France
insoumise d'être à l'origine des
débordements lors des manifestations
spontanées votre violence verbale à
déborder dans la rue leur a-t-elle dit à
l'Assemblée vous partagez ça oui
totalement totalement je trouve que la
France insoumise à maltraiter
l'Assemblée nationale et a maltraiter
nos institutions qui sont l'expression
de ces 67 millions de Français on n'a
pas le droit de dégrader l'image de la
France à travers ce type de comportement
ce sont des chahuts d'étudiants post 68
ares ce ne sont pas des représentations
nationales de la vie publique
merci Thierry Rabier merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous le coup de gueule
des commerçants c'est à la une de
l'édition de Rouen de Paris Normandie
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Thierry
d'avoir été avec nous depuis Rouen un
dernier mot sur le nucléaire puisque
c'est un dossier que vous suivez
particulièrement Gérard long galet
député ont voté hier le texte sur la
relance du nucléaire mais sans la
réforme de la sûreté nucléaire c'est
l'exécutif qui voulait fondre l'Institut
de radioprotection et de sûreté
nucléaire avec l'autorité sur tes
nucléaire ça a été retoqué est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose ah non c'est pas
une bonne chose il nous faut une seule
autorité de sûreté nucléaire pour les
centrales nucléaires je parle bien
nucléaire énergie il y a d'autres sujets
sur le nucléaire mais en ce qui concerne
l'énergie il faut une autorité qui soit
dirigée par un collège un collège
c'est-à-dire des scientifiques reconnus
qui engagent leurs paroles et qui ne
s'exprime qu'après avoir échangé entre
eux pour arriver à un consensus ce que
fait le l'ASM
c'est plutôt un institut de recherche
qui n'a de mon point de vue pas autorité
pour s'exprimer publiquement ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas l'écouter au
contraire et donc le gouvernement a
raison de privilégier une seule autorité
d'expression de la sécurité c'était pas
dans le texte que vous avez voté en
premier les sénateurs lovote en premier
et le gouvernement n'avait pas réfléchi
à cette possibilité je ne vais pas lui
reprocher moi qui suis reconnaissons le
pronucléaire je vais pas lui reprocher
de rattraper un retard mais si le texte
revient vous pensez que les sénateurs
voteront en faveur de tous les cas je
défendrai ce point de vue et j'espère
convaincre mes collègues merci Gérard
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on parlera de la
sécheresse hivernale c'est la journée
mondiale de l'eau aujourd'hui la
sécheresse hivernale touche notre pays
et avec des conséquences on ira dans le
Puy-de-Dôme dans un village qui a été en
partie privée d'eau mais d'abord on va
accueillir notre prochaine invité c'est
Brice Vallot qui ne